hi my name is Eric singer I'm a dialect
coach you may have seen me here before
talking about accent performances and
movies but at Texas accents and South
Asian accents have in common
the answer is retroreflection so today
I'm going to offer you some quick and
easy ways to tell one accent apart from
another when those two accents are
pretty similar in a lot of ways can you
ask somebody to say a simple phrase to
try to tell whether they're from say
Australia or New Zealand
I'm originally from Sydney Australia
Lily pa New Bedford Massachusetts number
one how to tell an Australian from a New
Zealand er we can use the kit foul in
Australia there's a realization that is
not too far off from my own American
accent for instance something like an e
sound an Australian might say that's
something like this myth myth myth New
Zealanders tend to centralize this sound
so instead of the tongue being arched up
a little bit towards the front of the
mouth it's relaxed down a little bit
towards the middle of the mouth and you
get something closer to a schwa the good
you can hear that here men men men myth
myth myth myth so there's one actually
very famous phrase that you can use that
you could ask somebody at a cocktail
party say to pronounce to try to tell
whether they're an Australian or New
Zealand er if you're not sure and that
phrase would be fish and chips
an Australian might say that's something
like this fish and chips
fish and chips fish and chips whereas
the New Zealand version might sound more
like this fish and chips
fish and chips fish and chips fish and
chips
chips number two how to tell somebody
from the north of England from somebody
from the South of England
[Music]
many accents in both places of course
but the cool thing is you can draw a
line straight across England north of
that line struck words words like cup
under mother love son are gonna have a
vowel sound something like ooh very
similar to the vowel sound named foot
words like would butcher woman look here
is a northern English person and you can
hear their Strutt vowel call in the
South they're gonna be two different
bells one is strut and one is foot and
they won't sound the same here's a
speaker from the south cop cop cop from
the north fun fun fun so if you meet
somebody and you're pretty sure that
their accent is from somewhere in
England but you want to know whether
it's from the north or from the South
you could ask them to say the following
phrase did you cut your foot from the
north from South cut your foot cut your
foot cut your foot cut your foot cut
your foot so of course there are many
different northern English accents two
famous ones are Geordie from Newcastle
and Brummie from Birmingham one way that
you could potentially tell a Geordie
accent from a Brummie accent would be to
take the face well a Brummie is going to
have a sound that's kind of similar to a
London sound it's a diphthong it's a
vowel sound that starts and ends up e
moves from I it takes a journey so if
you hear something like this gripe kegs
gripe gripe gripe you're dealing with a
Brahmi if you hear something that's much
more monophthong a something like this
great
kicks great great great then you're
dealing with a Geordie phrase could be
David bakes grape cakes you can hear
that here David bicks great kick David
banks great cats they excrete kicks
thanks Greg cats
screw kicks next up New York and Boston
[Music]
now this one's probably easier to hear
in place if you're American probably
less so if you're not an American the
lot bowel is going to be very open
fronted no lip rounding in a New York
accent
lot hot not god here's a New York
speaker not-not-not
it's gonna be a little bit lip rounded
in a Boston accent so more like law God
here's a Boston speaker not not not not
not not not so here's a phrase you could
ask somebody to say that's not a lot of
pots if they say it with an AA that's
not a lot of pots they're probably from
New York that's not a lot of pots that's
not a lot of pots if they say with an
awl that's not a lot of pots that Boston
that's not a lot of pots that's not a
lot of pots that's not a lot of pots
next up New York City in Philadelphia so
both New York City in Philadelphia raise
the trap foul in certain circumstances
so you'll get air instead of ah they do
it in different places in New York
accent you get trash and traffic
you also get sad and bad here's a New
York speaker trash trash trash where is
in Philadelphia those are not some of
those trap words that are going to get
raised we get other ones like man and
hand so you'll get something more open
like my own ah traffic trash sad bad
here's a Philadelphia speaker on similar
words with a different sound traffic
traffic traffic so if you want a quick
cocktail party test you could have
somebody say trash for traffic Trish
Trish traffic traffic Trish traffic
Trish traffic that's it for accent party
tricks I'm Eric singer
[Music]